wir starten mal mit der nato zwei
stunden haben jens stoltenberg heute und
olaf scholz gemeinsam beraten die nato
hat ein problem mitten in diesem krieg
und das hat einen namen
guter erdogan böser erdogan spielt der
türkische staatspräsident ein doppeltes
spiel
erst gestern gab sich die türkei wieder
freundlich versuchte im ukraine konflikt
zu vermitteln
wenn beide seiten zusammenkommen wahl
stehen wir als gast geben das land gerne
bereit sowie in antalya und istanbul
noch einmal wir sind bereit alles zu tun
was wir können
recep erdogan als fairer makler europa
kennt ihn anders zuletzt wetterte er
gegen die aufnahme von schweden und
finnland in die nato
und er will dabei bleiben
wir sind sehr besorgt über diese zwei
länder vor allem über schweden und dass
so etwas wie eine heimat für terrorist
erdogan provoziert wo er kann in
nordsyrien kündigt er ausgerechnet jetzt
eine neue offensive gegen kurden an und
im dauerkonflikt mit nato partner
griechenland bricht er den kontakt zu
seinem kollegen mitsotakis brust ab
von nun an gibt es für mich keinen
mitsotakis mehr
ich will mich mit ihm nicht wieder
treffen
generell ist bei uns journalist von der
welt erdogan war eigentlich immer das
problem wer wüsste das besser als sie
sie saßen ein jahr in türkischer haft
denn es
kann er in dieser situation kann er in
diesem krieg an teil der lösung sein
das weiß ich nicht aber
ich hab' ich hatte eine andere
befürchtung ich hatte die befürchtung
vor einigen monaten zu beginn des
krieges als die türkei soll als
vermittler auf spielt auch auf spielte
oder anbot in istha mode und den antalya
es sah so aus als würde jetzt hier keine
internationale aufwertung
wieder fahren und ich dachte das ist so
das kann doch nicht die lehre dieses
ukraine krieges sein dass wir sagen wie
auch die deutsche politik gegenüber
russland ist gescheitert das war ein
fehler mit autokraten autokraten sind
keine potenziell verlässlichen partner
auch der der moment wo ein auto cortina
diktatur wandeln kann das ist das ist
das kann sehr schnell gehen und das
ergebnis und dann der er dort
aufgewertet und um dann in fünf jahren
in zehn jahren zu sagen wo wir uns in
der türkei politik geehrt und deswegen
habe ich bei
problematisch dass jetzt für die nato
ist die die blockade des nato beitritts
von schweden und finnland finden kann
ich dem etwas positives abgewinnen weil
das daran erinnert worum es in diesem
krieg geht es geht natürlich zuerst die
ukraine es geht um die verteidigung der
ukraine aber es geht auch um das was man
oft so westliche werte nennt man könnte
es auch sagt zivilisatorische wert es
geht um rechtsstaatlichkeit und freiheit
und grundrechte
gleichberechtigung der geschlechter
offene gesellschaft all das was an putin
hast was an erdogan hast und dass das
eher neue kreisel haben sich quasi wie
der dekoriert genau und deswegen finde
ich diese das ist das besser so rum und
ich finde ist ich finde das höchst
problematisch wenn der westen erdogan
jetzt zugeständnisse machen würde ihn
beitrag wurden ja die grunde schon
angerissen dass es bei erdogan
außenpolitik hängt auch immer mit
innenpolitik zusammen aber ich bin noch
mal erinnern die kurden um die es hier
geht das sind die kurden die vor acht
jahren als die welt genau so passgenau
so gebannt auf kubanische haben die uns
alle der banken genau die die jurys nach
gerät haben sie uns alle gerettet dabei
auch ihre partei herr weber ich erinnere
mich an äußerung von herrn kauder zum
beispiel damals fraktionsvorsitz der
sagte zur not müssen wir die pkk
bewaffnet um diese barbarei im namen des
islam diese barbarei aufzuhalten das
haben die kurden gemacht und jetzt in
dieser situation die kunden wurden
seither auch vom westen immer wieder
verraten und das ist jetzt mal eine
große befürchtung dass man erpressung
spiel mitspielt und die kurden einmal
mehr verrät und das sollte nicht
passiert die nicht passieren manfred
weber schon angesprochen neuer
vorsitzender dvp der europäischen
volkspartei vorsitzender und
fraktionsvorsitzender natürlich der
spiegel schrieb erdogan habe sich als
doppelagent geriert doppelagenten können
sehr gefährlich sein aber sie können
auch nützlich sein wie interpretieren
sie das spiel dass erdogan spiel das
zunächst mal ist brandgefährlich weil
was wir brauchen in unserer
wertegemeinschaft wir sind und sind uns
einig es geht man werte konflikt nicht
nur mal konflikt zwischen zwei ländern
russland der ukraine und in diesem werde
konflikt brauchen wir einheit und
geschlossenheit das alles was sie jetzt
aufhört brandgefährlich und die liste
sehr lange also bei den flüchtlingen
genauso versucht europa zu erpressen an
der grenze dafür zu sorgen dass mit
bussen menschen an die grenze gefahren
werden und bilder zu produzieren als an
vielen ecken versucht europa zu
erpressen und deswegen bin ich der
meinung es hilft da nur entschiedenheit
und stärke
das wird nicht nur moskau beantworten
können wir nur vladimir putin
beantworten können für mich ist die
frage stellen ob es vermittlungen aber
es gespräche gibt auch zutiefst
ukrainische frage die ukrainische
politik entscheiden muss und nicht wie
in berlin aber um die türkei zu bleiben
stärke heißt auch der türkei zu zeigen
sie haben ökonomisch enorme probleme in
der türkei auch zu zeigen dass mit
europäischen union nicht zu spaßen ist
die europäische union auch jede
machtmittel diese hat beispielsweise
zugang zum binnenmarkt die werden wir
auch nutzen um dafür zu sorgen dass wir
dort einen partner bekommen der auf
augenhöhe mit uns arbeitet man muss sich
nur mal vergegenwärtigen wir reden von
schweden finnland zwei zutiefst
demokratische soziale länder die die
typisch klassische europäisch denken und
ticken und die wollen jetzt mitglied
dieser wertegemeinschaft dieser
verteidigungsgemeinschaft werden
willkommen sage ich doch nur und
insofern muss mag in der türkei da
konnte ziehen und dann ist die frage wie
man der türkei das ab verhandelt oder
abverkauf dazu kommen wir noch freuen
uns über claudia roth die
staatssekretärin für kultur und eine
gute türkei kennerin muss man im besten
sinne sagen
putin ist das ist nicht neu frau roth
reklamiert teile der ukraine für sich
wenn erdogan das jetzt in bezug auf
teile des nordirak und syriens tut was
ist da eigentlich sogar an also ich gebe
dennis jale wirklich recht ich glaube
wir zahlen jetzt ein stück weit den
preis für eine politische abhängigkeit
wer mehr gesehen wenn man abhängig ist
von gas und öl von herrn putin was da
rauskommt und wir haben eine politische
abhängigkeit seit langer zeit mit
erdogan mit seiner türkei es gibt ja
auch noch die andere türkei das darf man
nicht vergessen und er benutzt die eben
versucht sie zu benutzen ab reißerisch
zu benutzen wie will denn jemand
friedenslösungen verhandeln der
gleichzeitig in syrien
völkerrechtswidrige angriffe fährt der
gleichzeitig im nord-irak
völkerrechtswidrig militärische angriffe
führt der in der türke der in
griechenland sich unsäglich provokant
gegen griechenland positioniert das ist
sein spiel ja er versucht sich sozusagen
außenpolitisch als macht darzustellen
mit verlaub er hat auch eine gewisse
macht das muss man einfach eingestehen
wenn ich mir anschaue erkannt den
bosporus auf oder zu machen und er
versucht innenpolitisch zu punkten darum
geht es natürlich auch im nächsten jahr
sind wahlen in der türkei
und da muss er von einem schlechten
wirtschaftlichen schlechten
wirtschaftlichen belangen aber wir haben
uns eben abhängig gemacht in der
flüchtlingsfrage weil er sozusagen die
flüchtlingsabwehr politik mit
unterstützt hat und die nato hat mit
verlaub über lange zeit keine reaktion
gezeigt auch viele angriffe die erdogan
geführt hat sei es auf nato partner oder
sei es in syrien und sei es im nord
ihrer sein erpressungspotenzial war
offensichtlich immer stärker wenn du das
ist bei uns aus europa expertin jahre
lang befassen sie sich mit russland und
mit der ukraine und vor allen dingen
eben mit den aus europäischen ländern
frau setzte ich würde gerne als erstes
nach diesem zitat von angie du da den
polnischen präsident gerne heute fragen
wollen der hat kritisiert und zwar sehr
kritisiert das makro und olaf scholz so
ausführlich mit putin telefonieren
finden sie eigentlich auch das zuviel
von berlin und pariser seite mit putin
telefoniert wird und welchen eindruck
erweckt dass gerade bei den osteuropäern
nicht ganz kurz auch noch bei den beiden
anderen bleiben darf und dann komme ich
auf die telefonate zu sprechen ich wenn
die türkei und wenn er dann überhaupt
eine eine mögliche vermittlerrolle hat
spielen können dann dann verspielt er
sie jetzt gerade also aus der ukraine
kann er natürlich ab diesem zeitpunkt
gar nicht mehr als ein neutraler
vermittler oder jemand der zumindest in
äquidistanz zum westen und zu russland
wenn man das wäre meine nächste frage
gewesen weil wir ihn ja bis gestern in
unseren gedanken immer noch hatten und
dachten eher könnten potenzielle helfer
beim zustandekommen von verhandlungen
sein wie gehen die verhandlungs die
potentielle verhandlungspartner weiter
durch stichworte ist ist es gut zu
diesem wladimir putin weiter einen so
engen telefonischen kontakt zu halten
ich weiß gar nicht wie wie eng dieser
kontakt wirklich ist natürlich wird es
ankommt dass kommen diese vorwürfe
insbesondere auch aus polen vor dem
hintergrund natürlich einer schlecht
gelaufenen kommunikation dieser
regierung vor dem hintergrund der
tatsache dass nach wie vor keine
schweren waffen angekommen sind aus
deutschland in der ukraine es geht also
nicht nur um diese telefonate und den
macht man jetzt einen einen größeren
punkt fest generell ist es natürlich
richtig dass man weiterhin austestet
wann der moment für für diplomatie kommt
allerdings sind die signale die aus
berlin und auch aus paris kommen die
gehen darüber hinaus und im moment ist
einfach deutlich zu sehen dass es keinen
verhandlungsspielraum gibt aber dieser
telefonate die an denen sollte man das
nicht nur festmachen die sind auch dafür
da um zu sehen ob sich irgendetwas
verändert aber auf jeden fall ist ja
weder die nato noch die eu dieser tage
geeint und darauf zielt dieses
politischen zitaten natürlich ab darauf
zielt das polnische zitat aber darauf
zielt am ende doch auch alles was wir
mehr putin tut im grunde streit zwischen
die nato partner und die europäischen
partner zu bringen und das tut er mit
erfolg fragezeichen das wird das thema
unserer sendung sein wir freuen uns dass
auch el mati winsen und zugeschaltet ist
aus washington der leiter des
zdf-studios in den vereinigten staaten
immer gehen wir noch einmal zurück zu
erdogan er blockiert ja nicht nur
innerhalb der nato er streitet sich mit
griechenland er operiert in syrien mit
den islamisten warum protestiert darüber
und dazu nicht eigentlich auch der
us-amerikanische präsident warum dazu
von beiden kein wort weil er erdogan er
auf diese vermittler position sie
also hier in washington ist man
natürlich sehr genervt von erdogan
manche sagen sogar die kriterien die
jetzt finnland und schweden erfüllen
müssen um mitglied der nato zu werden
die würde erdogans türkei wohlgemerkt
erdogans türkei heute gar nicht mehr
erfüllen man würde also ein
aufnahmeantrag aus der türkei verweigern
wenn erdogan einen antrag stellen müsste
also ist hier die frage zumindest im
hintergrund im raum muss man nicht die
bündnisse neu sortieren aber im weißen
haus sagte beiden eigentlich sehr klar
und deutlich wir müssen jetzt erst mal
versuchen lösungen zu finden und man
glaubt hier dass das eine frage des
preises ist erdogan will etwas allen
voran von washington er möchte
modernisierungs pakete für die f 16
kampfflugzeuge haben die ja schon hat
würde gern noch viel mehr brandneue
f-16-kampfflugzeuge bekommen die kriegt
er nicht gibt es keine zustimmung im
amerikanischen kongress aber es gibt
auch wirtschaftliche interessen und da
ist es vielleicht eine lösung das was
beiden im juli vor hat er will im juli
nach juli nach saudi arabien reisen und
erdogan hat ein riesiges interesse die
beziehungen zu saudi arabien wieder zu
normalisieren auch wirtschaftlich
auszubauen im bezug auf das öl
beispielsweise erdogan ist selber ende
ab in saudi arabien gewesen und
möglicherweise kann so ein
dreiecksgeschäft entstehen so hofft man
hier jedenfalls wenn präsident biden
vermittelt aber man hat hier schon das
gefühl dass erdogan zunehmend ein
hoffnungsloser fall ist das heißt man
könnte auf diese rüstungsgeschäfte
eingehen emma und auf der anderen seite
auch auf die auslieferung aktivistischer
boden wird das dann überhaupt erwogen
nein also da wird keine
kompromissbereitschaft sein weil das ein
kotau wäre der in rom signalisiert all
das was beiden ja postuliert es geht
hier um eine auseinandersetzung zwischen
demokratien und dem autoritär ismus das
würde durch so eine entscheidung ja
unterlaufen werden ich glaube hier sieht
man übrigens auch kritisch ein telefonat
mit putin es kommt am ende darauf an was
man putin signalisiert wenn man
signalisiert wir bleiben geschlossen wir
erwarten dass du dich zurück zieht und
so ist ein telefonat in ordnung wenn
aber in einem telefonat ein signal
gesendet würde wir suchen unbedingt nach
einem ausweg wir brauchen eine lösung
dann ist das ein zeichen der schwäche
aus washingtoner sicht und man will
eigentlich sehr klar machen auch durch
die weitere unterstützung für die
ukraine dass die usa mit langem atem die
ukraine mit allen mitteln unterstützen
bisher lenski selber der ukrainische
präsident zu dem schluss kommt aus einer
position der stärke heraus
möglicherweise ein kompromiss zu suchen
das waren die letzten äußerungen
interessant ist noch mal die frage an
manfred weber dass die türkei ja
wirklich double bein spielt sie hat auf
der einen seite aus russland waffen
gekauft und hat auf der anderen seite an
die ukraine
waffen verkauft die drohnen verkauft die
durchaus auch eine rolle gespielt haben
bei der verteidigung des land ist also
offensichtlich ist er ein spieler und
auch ein anerkannter spieler so man das
sagen darf auf beiden feldern
wird es am ende so sein dass man sich
erdogan zustimmung erkauft herr weber
bei den waffen oder sich zunächst mal
verzockt weil ja die amerikaner deshalb
die modernisierung verweigern weil er in
russland eingekauft hat und diesen auf
den technologien jetzt versucht
insofern insofern hat er sich da erst
mal verzockt
ich will lösung ich sagte einerseits
müsse mehr druck ausüben ich hab vorher
die wirtschaftliche dimension
beschrieben die für die türkei alles
andere als gut ist ist auch in europa
herausfordernd das ist anderes thema
auch im konflikt mit putin können wir
langfristig ezb entscheidung von heute
mit den zinssätzen die inflation die wir
haben haben wir wirtschaftlich auch die
standhaftigkeit europas und
langfristigen konflikt mit russland
auszuhalten das heißt es wird uns alle
fordern aber das sage ich auch druck
ausüben aber vertan und andererseits
macht gesprächsangebote man muss sehen
wenn die aufnahme von finnland und
schweden mittelfristig blockiert werden
würde wirklich blockiert werden würden
wir zu keinem einen kompakten angebot
kommen dann ist natürlich ein schwerer
schaden für die geschlossenheit der
westlichen staatengemeinschaft deshalb
bin ich für beides druck ausüben aber
auch gesprächsbereitschaft und damit
sind wir bei ben hodges den ehemaligen
oberbefehlshaber des us heeres in europa
er ist uns heute abend zugeschaltet aus
frankfurt und ich begrüße ihnen sehr
herzlich guten abend ben hodges nach
frankfurt wenn die einigkeit des westens
ihr großer trumpf ist wie sie sagen und
wie sie sehr klug sagen wie viele sorgen
müssen wir uns dann machen
am wirken sollen ich bin selbst sehr
besorgen die einheit unserer allianz bis
dieser eine punkt der putin gene halten
lässt
und der druck auf diese einheit aus so
vielen richtung nicht nur von präsident
erdogan seite aus oder von
premierminister orban ist betrachtet
sind genau diese dinge die ist für uns
erforderlich machen gemeinsam weiter
zusammen zu arbeiten ich bin sehr stolz
muss ich sagen auf meinen präsidenten
präsident biden hat sehr gut sehr gute
arbeit geleistet um diese einheit auch
mit anderen staatschefs weiter
herzustellen können wir ganz konkret
auch sie nochmal nach recep erdogan
fragen wird man seitens der nato
finnland die zustimmung zu finnland und
schweden der türkei dem türkischen
präsidenten
abdullah
öcalan geben letztlich weiß die türkei
das ihre langfristige sicherheit
natürlich auch davon abhängt ein teil
dieser allianz zu sein und trotz aller
herausforderungen allem frust oder
vielleicht damit zusammen hängen dass
die türkei und so an dem elite ist seit
den fünfziger jahren kann ich mir doch
keine nato ohne die türkei vorstellen
präsident erdogan ist tatsächlich
ziemlich erbost über die vereinigten
staaten hier geht es nicht um schweden
oder den hat es geht um die vereinigten
staaten erst erbost weil wir die p g
unterstützt haben sie heute gehen weil
er in waffen gegeben haben im kampf
gegen den bsv es gibt diesen grund
vielleicht noch ein paar andere gründe
deshalb neben den vereinigten staaten
nicht wirklich traut und vielleicht auch
europa nicht trauen und natürlich gibt
es auf den punkt da schon angesprochen
würde nämlich dass im nächsten jahr
wichtige wahlen anstehen und ein teil
davon ist also ein für sein versuch
stärken zu zeigen und er wird auch
versuchen da es etwas gab zu verhandeln
aber natürlich müssen auch seine und die
sicherheitsbedenken der türkei mit auch
akzeptiert und berücksichtigt werden
wenn es darum geht ihr zu überzeugen
seinen einspruch gegen die aufnahme von
finnland schweden zu geben ich glaube er
hat sich allerdings auch selbst schon
beschädigt er bereits sein blatt und er
wird letztlich zustimmen aber die
menschen werden sich natürlich daran
erinnern und es sieht einfach nicht
besonders
wenn man sich das anschaut und noch ein
letzter punkt wir in den vereinigten
staaten müssen aber auch unsere
beziehung zum teil noch einmal
reparieren ich möchte damit kein
schlechtes warten oder schlechte
entscheidung der türkei rechtfertigen
aber ich glaube auch wir haben fehler in
der vergangenheit gemacht der landkarte
anschauen an die ukraine dort sehen dann
müssen wir auch die türkei im hinterkopf
behalten und diese beziehung reparieren
wir müssen diese beziehung reparieren
sagen sie und dennoch ist ja augenfällig
dass wir mit viktor orban und mit
erdogan in eu und nato offensichtlich in
dieser unserer wertegemeinschaft
eigene despoten dulden und eigene
despoten haben wie sehr können wir dann
noch einen einigen eindruck und einen
einheitlichen eindruck hinterlassen
wirklich sehr guter punkt in der
präambel des vertrags von washington der
die nato auf tatsächlich ihre grundlage
stellt da geht es ja nicht nur um die
verteidigung sondern eben auch um den
geist dieses bündnisses und es ist auch
unrealistisch natürlich immer zu
erwarten dass alle mitglieder dieser
allianzen oder auch der eu sich wie die
engel verhalten aber wir haben auch in
den vereinigten staaten eine gewisse
verantwortung unseren eigenen punkten zu
entsprechen wenn wir über diese werte
sprechen wir müssen hier bestimmte
standards vorgeben bevor wir druck auf
andere länder ausüben können das heißt
auch aus der amerikanischen perspektive
haben wir selbst einige arbeit noch zu
leisten und dann haben wir natürlich
auch einen größeren hebel gegenüber der
türkei ungarn oder anderen ländern wenn
es darum geht diese werte einzuhalten
beispielsweise bei der pressefreiheit
aber es ist eben auch ganz wichtig dass
wir hier das kind nicht mit dem bade
ausschütten der die große mehrzahl der
mitglieder der allianz und auch der eu
sind natürlich auf der seite dieser
werte füllen sie mit leben und deswegen
gibt es eben auch so viele länder die
eben zur nato und zur eu dazu kommt und
genau aus diesem grunde und welches sind
die positionen an denen sie sagen die
usa müsste das eigene verhältnis und die
eigene politik verändern
ich habe in meinem leben nie vorstellen
können dass so etwas wie am sechsten
januar überhaupt hier geschehen würden
dass menschen das capitol stürmen nie in
meinem leben hätte ich mir vorstellen
können dass der oberste gerichtshof als
eine solche politische institution
betrachtet würde und im augenblick ist
ist da ist das sind eigentlich säulen
der amerikanischen demokratie und auch
der demokratie im gesamten westen wenn
sie so wollen und sie sind flex worden
durch die andauernden angriffe der
rechten in den usa beispielsweise wenn
es darum geht den wahlprozess und
zweifel zu ziehen wenn ein früherer
präsident alles fake news nennt was ihm
nicht passte und natürlich entspricht er
dann mit seiner pflicht die verfassung
zu verteidigen gerade wenn es darum geht
beispielsweise auch die freie presse zu
schützen das sind also bereiche wo wir
selbst tatsächlich noch viel arbeit im
eigenen haus zu leisten haben natürlich
werden wir das irgendwann auch schaffen
aber wie gesagt es ist eine ganze menge
arbeit die in diesem bereich noch uns
wartet vielleicht können wir noch mal
auf das schauen was in der ukraine
geschieht auch da macht sich und machen
sich unterschiede bereit wir haben
eingangs schon vom alten europa gegen
das neue europa gesprochen die ost
ukraine die balten auch großbritannien
stehen auf der einen seite und fordern
mehr härte die westeuropäer berlin paris
rom
deuten eher mehr
verhandlungsbereitschaft an um diesen
krieg möglichst bald zu beenden
was denken sie wie kann man diesen spalt
überwinden
woher willst du das ist eine ganz
wichtige frage denn jedes land jede
nation nur in europa hat ein interesse
an dem ergebnis dieses konfliktes in der
ukraine das wird uns alle betreffen was
die sicherheit angeht das
wirtschaftliche fragen angeht aber auch
mit bezug auf die werte über die längere
gesprochen haben und ich glaube niemand
der sich ernsthaft mit der geschichte
auseinandersetzt und der sich anschaut
was muss man in den vergangenen 20
jahren getan hat wird wirklich daran
glauben dass der russische präsident
sich verlässlich auf irgendetwas an und
wenn jetzt ein waffenstillstand haben
dann wird also die gewinne werden die
gewinne von russland festgeschrieben das
wäre im augenblick der worst case wenn
sie so wollen ist weiß und verstehe
weshalb bestimmte nationen und gerne
schnell eine einigung erreichen würde
aber jetzt die ukraine aufzufordern und
20 prozent ihres landes aufzugeben nur
damit sein waffenstillstand gibt ich
kann mir kaum vorstellen dass der
bundeskanzler oder der präsident von
frankreich oder der präsident von
italien sagen ach wissen sie was ich
gebe 20 prozent italiens oder meines
landes ab dem ein waffenstillstand zu
erzählen und hier müssen die vereinigten
staaten und deutschland zusammen
arbeiten mal wird sie wissen dass ich
habe mit ihnen schon darüber gesprochen
ich glaube dass deutschland in diesem
zusammenhang der wichtigste agierte der
vereinigten staaten ist vielleicht nicht
immer unser liebster aber ganz sicher
unser wichtigster verbündeter und ich
glaube dass der größte teil europas dem
freundin wird was deutschland und das
ist wirklich die chance für kanzler
stolz zu sagen das hier ist so wichtig
dass wir eben einen gewissen preis dafür
zahlen werden aber wir werden helfen die
ukraine zu verteidigen und wir werden
alles tun damit sind mir gerüttelt
gebiete zurückgewinnen können dass sie
nicht verlieren und nichts was dem nicht
entspricht werden wir hier im
akzeptieren ich glaube das ist die
wichtige rolle deutschlands und das wird
auch erwartet und vielleicht können wir
genau an der stelle die runde wieder
öffnen und sagen dankenswerterweise
sprechen sie nicht nur mit mir sondern
versprechen vor etlichen zuschauern und
teilweise auch mit anderen gästen
individuell eine entscheidende frage in
diesem zusammenhang olaf scholz sagt
immer wieder wie viel die deutsche
bundesregierung tut sagte gerade wieder
dass sie vor allen dingen mehr tut als
andere und herausragend viel tut warum
kommt das bei den osteuropäern nicht
andenken sie herr zunächst kommt man
kommt die sachen die deutschland
verspricht die bundesregierung
verspricht in den in der ukraine nicht
an also ich habe uns nochmal mit
ukrainischen quellen gesprochen die
panzer die schweren waffen die die
zuliefernden bundestag beschlossen hat
ende april sind immer noch nicht
angekommen ende juni soll sieben
panzerhaubitzen
gesagt glaube ich mich richtig erinnere
ende juni sollen die ankommt und zwei
monate nach dem bundestagsbeschluss
polen hat vergleichbare schwere
einheiten von waffen 18 jetzt in der
letzten hat gelebt hat norwegen 22
frankreich hat geliefert wie haben die
bundes deutschland hat immer noch nicht
geliefert woran das liegt das noch mal
das ist eine eigene frage aber es ist
nicht nur und das geht ja das zieht sich
seit einem halben jahr so dass
angefangen ende letzten jahres wollte
herr scholz noch eine politische lösung
über nord 2 und das ging jeder einzelne
punkt der hier diskutiert wurde und ich
glaube es war nicht die ganze
bundesregierung das ist ja
offensichtlich ich finde es ja auch
großartig dass claudia roth geradeaus
auch deshalb zurück gekehrt ist
annalena baerbock aber da ich glaube das
ist nicht die bundesregierung ist es
sondern maßgeblich die spd und ist in
der inter versteckt auch die fdp ganz
ähnlich die sich da zum jagen tragen
lässt trotz aller bekundungen und
zeitenwende und so weiter ich wollte
einen punkt und ich noch aufgaben mit
dem stichwort glaubwürdigkeit gang ja
wir sind uns darin einig das ist hier
auch dass es nicht nur in die ukraine
geht sondern um werte der zivilisation
um westliche werte manchmal ich finde
ein falscher weise genannt weil das eine
universelle werte
aber wir haben ein problem mit
glaubwürdigkeit und ich das sehe ich
auch so aber ich glaube das
glaubwürdigkeitsproblem das ist weiter
als nur mit trump und dem für den
putschversuch in den usa das war ein
besonders krasses beispiel aber ein ganz
ein harmloser harmlos aber ein einfaches
beispiel
erlangt der umgang mit mit julian
assange der seit elf jahren und in
unfreiheit ist abu ghraib der um die die
alanco die der als symbolfigur der
flüchtlingskrise an europa das sich von
menschen fürchtet dass sich erpressbar
macht wenn lukaschenko tausend menschen
meistens kurden übrigens auch in die
daten die grenze card und natürlich sie
auf zynische weise als waffe benutzt ist
es natürlich auch ein europa das sich
davon erpressen lässt und ich glaube
dieser
glaubwürdigkeitsverlust den euro hatte
die westliche welt in
den letzten 20 30 jahren erlitten hat
ich glaube dass das teil das ist teil
der ursache weswegen eine situation in
der arabischen welt immer an das dass
das eben also wenn wir über so etwas
reden warum auch mal lässt man könnte
sich auch das auch am beispiel der
türkei auch durchdeklinieren die türkei
die auch sogar noch mit erdogan vor 20
jahren sich in richtung westen
orientiert hat und warum das so ist
warum ein ungarn nach nach dem beitritt
in die eu sich in richtung autokratie
beträgt das hat natürlich das hat auch
was mit dem glaubt mit dem verlust von
glaubwürdigkeit zu tun dass wir es in
der westlichen welt mit den werten die
wir in so kunden wie ich hier immer
hochhalten in der realität leider nicht
immer so hoch aber vielleicht können wir
noch mal eine frage zurück an den wänden
hodges stellen damit wir bei dem thema
versuchen ein bisschen klarer zu sehen
sie sind sehr gut informiert was
anlieferungen am boden überhaupt von der
polnisch ukrainischen grenze eben das
ukrainische kampfgebiet kommt können sie
uns ben hodges noch mal sagen wie ist
der definitiven beitrag der deutschen
und ist das eine kampagne der
osteuropäer sich an den deutschen da so
abzuarbeiten oder gibt es gründe
berechtigte gründe daran zu zweifeln
darf dann möchte ich erst einmal
hergestellt kurz widersprechen denn
alles was deutschland offiziell
versprochen hat ist entweder schon
geliefert worden oder ist auf dem weg
mit der ausnahme der haube während wir
hier heute abend sprechen sind diese
hätten entweder oberstein die in der
bergschule wert deutscher streitkräfte
und die ukrainischen streitkräfte die
dieser haubitzen bedienen werden diesen
auch immer wieder oberstein und sie
werden dort ausgebildet und gegen ende
juni ist diese ausbildung abgeschlossen
und dann wird es über polen in die
ukraine gehen aber er hat reicht es ist
schritt wir sind alle sehr spät mit
unseren reaktionen gewesen auch die
feindlichen staaten
raketenwerfer systeme gehen natürlich
könnte deutschland vielleicht auch mehr
machen aber ich glaube zu viele
europäische länder verstärken sich der
deutschen deutschland hat mehr geliefert
als frankreich aber es gibt diese
konzentration auf das was deutschland
trend und es gibt die kritik dass
deutschland nicht genug legte aber das
hat glaube ich auch viel
damit zu tun dass es vielleicht
deutschland fast ein wenig peinlich
berührt ist wenn es darum geht zu
erläutern was sie tun das heißt nehmen
wird auch nicht wirklich dann auch gut
geschrieben was sie wirklich schauen
aber es gibt auch in der ukraine das
problem der
distributionsnetzwerk zwischen nachholen
und der front im osten der ukraine das
ist kein sehr großes netzwerk deshalb
züge lastwagen die infrastruktur die es
braucht um all diese schwere material
und die munition dorthin zu bewegen wo
es gebraucht das ist ein schwaches
netzwerk und das ist ein punkt gurt
deutschland und den niederlanden sieht
man mit der expertise im bereich der
schwer register vielleicht ihren rat
anbieten können vielleicht auch von
kräfte dennoch hat es natürlich nicht
grundlos die diskussion um die mader
gegeben die nach griechenland sollten
und dann nicht angekommen sind damit die
griechen dann altes um nicht zu sagen 40
jahre altes militärisches gerät
weitergeben und die glaubt immer noch in
rede stehen auch die leopards die den
spanien geliefert werden sollen da ist
jetzt angeblich der antrag noch nicht
angekommen also nochmal die frage sie
sagen ben hodges deutschland leistet und
ist nur ein schlechter verkäufer seiner
hilfe verstehe ich sie da richtig
war griechenland und spanien und das ist
dort geschehen es gab tatsächlich
darüber wie das aussehen könnte aber die
griechen beispielsweise haben ganz
besondere fahrzeuge angefordert spanien
eben auch und die in konten von
deutschland nicht einfach so zur
verfügung gestellt werden und das ist
dann eben an die öffentlichkeit gekommen
die sind nation sind damit unglücklich
und dann hört man das versprechen
gebrochen worden seien aber das stimmt
zwar nicht es gab diskussionen es gab
verhandlungen darüber aber es garten
noch keine übereinkunft darüber
unglücklicherweise ist es der person die
ich glaube ich war also ich möchte aber
auch keine schlechten entscheidungen
verteidigen oder irgendwie dass
deutschland jetzt langsam vielleicht war
aber es geht darum dass eben hier keine
versprechen gebrochen worden sind
sondern verhandlungs inhalte gelegt
worden sind wir sind dennis fiedel lebt
schon in den fingern vielleicht ist das
ein die nur er
[Gelächter]
verdrehte die bundesregierung gleich
gefragt so also wenn ich vielleicht darf
ich noch mal ganz kurz zu den leoparden
und den spanien fragen also der sagt
jetzt olaf scholz folgendes er sagt
dieser antrag ist noch nicht angekommen
und wenn der antrag angekommen ist
diesen ringtausch zu machen dann werden
wir den prüfen warum sagt ja nicht das
ist eine gute idee und wir werden gucken
was wir tun können ja der ringtausch
wird geprüft und es wird geliefert und
ich bin als grüne auch dafür dass
rüstungsgüter geliefert werden dass wir
die größtmögliche
rüstungs unterstützung für die ukraine
liefern und dafür die versprechen die
wir gemacht haben einhalten aber ich
will auch mal sagen mich stört wirklich
die reduzierung der debatte als ginge es
nur um rüstungsgüter als ginge es nur
noch um schwerere waffen und da finde
ich manchmal auch eine argumentation von
der opposition
zu schlicht immer nur darauf zu setzen
sondern dann guckt man mal an was auch
passiert wir haben eine milliarde budget
hilfe geleistet anders als andere wir
haben wir leisten unglaubliches bei der
minenräumung bei der forensik das
entwicklungsministerium das ministerium
für wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit hat
schon in der vergangenheit viel
geleistet svenja schulze war vor ort und
hat jetzt angefangen unterstützung zu
leisten für den wiederaufbau es gibt
unglaublich humanitäre hilfe annalena
baerbock hat sich sehr dafür eingesetzt
dass da richtig viel mittel zur
verfügung gestellt waren die absolut
notwendig sind und in unserem haus in
meinem haus im staatsministerium für
kultur versuchen wir eben auch genau
diese fragen anzugehen wie können wir in
einem krieg eines regimes das ein
souveränes land angegriffen hat und an
greift das kinder frauen männer tötet
das liegt aber dass auch einem krieg
gegen die kultur führt die kultur der
demokratie führt einen propagandakrieg
was können wir dagegen tun oder tun wir
sehr viel beispielsweise indem wir hier
versuchen eine exil medienstrategie
infrastruktur aufzubauen um der
propaganda was entgegenzusetzen
mich nervt es ein bisschen immer die
unterstellung man hält sich nicht an
versprechungen man tut nicht genug ich
kann nur sagen meine kolleginnen und
kollegen im kabinett die versuchen alles
zu tun cem özdemir ist jetzt im prater
in warschau um mit der polnischen
regierung zusammen zu überlegen wie
können wir die getreide lieferungen
organisieren das ist ein riesengroßes
problem in der arbeit und die
unterstellung dass da irgendwelche
verhandlungen geführt würden in
telefonaten ich gehe davon aus dass
unser bundeskanzler das tut was im
kabinett immer wieder gesagt ein
rosenkrieg so schnell endlich zu beenden
und deutlich zu machen dass es putins
aufgabe er muss sich zurückziehen muss
diesen mörderischen brutalen krieg
beenden wir sind ich frage auch gleich
frau saßen wir sind in der situation ja
nicht deutsche politiker und
oppositionsführer zu zitieren sondern
osteuropäische kollegen und freunde
sie telefonieren regelmäßig und viel mit
ihm vladimir putin
bisher ohne erfolg
ich bin erstaunt über die ganzen
gespräche die geführt werden mit putin
von kanzler scholz von präsident makro
diese gespräche bringen nichts hat
jemand so mit adolf hitler gesprochen
ost gegen west in der ukraine politik
geht ein riss durch europa frankreich
deutschland und auch italien bremsen in
sachen kriegsziele und waffen dagegen
entlädt sich im osten der frust vor
allem über deutschland
[Musik]
es sind die deutschen die sanktionen am
entschiedensten ausbremsten
und die estnische premierministerin
kajak einers klagte wir sind 65 mal
kleiner als deutschland
und wir haben sechs mal mehr
militärhilfe zur verfügung gestellt als
deutschland
ergebnis nach 100 tagen krisendiplomatie
das vertrauen in deutschland ist nahezu
bei null angekommen
klartext daher beim scholz besuch am
dienstag im baltikum
es kann keinen dialog oder kooperationen
geben keine peaceman oder zugeständnisse
gegenüber einem staat mit
imperialistischen ambitionen
das ist keine kritik unserer partner
unserer verbündeten frau roth da kann
man jetzt schlecht sagen das ist
irgendwie dann mal so ein gefühl oder es
ist eine kampagne oder die medien hätten
was dagegen da beschweren sich unsere
wichtigsten verbündeten
diese kritik die muss man ernst nehmen
aber den der kann man auch die reale die
realen handlungen und die realen
entscheidungen entgegen setzen noch
einmal
gegen ein telefonat ist doch nix
einzuführen wenn es klare worte sind
wenn es eine klare haltung ist und ich
habe keinen zweifel daran dass es nicht
eine klare haltung ist das nicht klar
gesagt wird wer ist für diesen krieg
unter diesen wahnsinn verantwortlich und
wer hat damit zu rechnen dass es weitere
sanktionen gibt ich tue mir schwer wenn
jetzt so hier plötzlich so ein eindruck
erweckt wird als sei die europäische
union so gespalten wie noch nie ich höre
von unserer außenministerin die seit
wochen und monaten unterwegs ist um
dieses europa mit zusammen zu binden um
die transatlantische beziehung als eine
enge beziehung zusammen zu binden dass
sie das gefühl hat und den eindruck hat
und die wahrnehmung hat dass wir eben
doch ziemlich stark beieinander sind ja
nicht ein sechser sanktionspaket gegeben
natürlich ärgert mich auch wenn herr
orban seine erpresserischen geschichten
macht und natürlich denke ich woran
liegt es dass solchen so einen eindruck
entsteht und das können wir dem
entgegensetzen aber ich weiß was getan
wird ich weiß wie agiert wird ich weiß
was die haltung ist und dann sind
bestimmte unterstellungen einfach nicht
zu rechtfertigen hassel wir sind bei
ihrem leib und magenthema sie können uns
erklären warum die osteuropäer so sehr
nicht nur das gefühl haben sondern sich
so sehr beschweren dass wir nicht genau
so tapfer und genauso aktiv und genauso
stark kämpfen gegen putin wie sie sich
das wünschen würden wie sie selbst tun
also zunächst muss man glaube ich mal
ganz klar sagen das ist nicht so einfach
in europa nahost und europa west und je
mehr wir davon sprechen dass spielt
wirklich eigentlich nur in die tasche
von labbadia
wie putin
also die idee dass die eu sich auf diese
geographischen oder politischen blöcke
reduzieren ließe das sehen wir dieser
tage gerade das stimmt nicht wir
sprechen ja auch schon gerade sehr viel
von ungarn ungarn ist in mittelosteuropa
aus europa hört man da sowieso überall
nicht gerne aber wenn es auch noch
mittel osteuropa ist dann dann ist das
ja schon keinen kein klarer blogger und
wir sehen wir hören dann unterstützt ist
gerade nicht genommen genau ungarn hat
enge beziehungen zu putin große
energieabhängigkeit hat das öl-embargo
ja so gestrickt das ist eigentlich nicht
ein richtiges in barkow ist das heißt
diese blöcke gibt es so nicht und die
sollten wir uns auch nicht einreden und
es auch neues und altes europa ich weiß
auch nicht was das sein soll das sind
auch keine hilfreichen begriffe hat ein
amerikanischer präsident mal davon genau
und war damals schon nicht hilfreich ist
es nicht selbst auch nicht hilfreich und
vielleicht sogar noch schädlicher
momentan die vehemenz mit denen mit der
deutschland kritisiert wird aus polen
und auch aus den baltischen ländern die
hat sich nicht erst jetzt aufgebaut aber
sie entlädt sich jetzt dann auch an wie
ich auch finde doch kleineren
detailfragen dieser telefonate um die es
ja eigentlich nicht gehen sollte ich
machen war eine waffenlieferung ist es
natürlich schon ein anderes thema aber
sie finden statt diese diese
anschuldigung vor dem hintergrund dass
man sich jahre jahrzehnte von der
deutschen politik übergangen fühlte wenn
es um beziehungen zu russland geht
insbesondere bei nord stream aber nicht
nur und ich denke auch selbst in der
bevölkerung scheint ja auch aus unserer
sicht polen häufig sehr weit weg und
dieses denken von das ist irgendwo weit
weg und anders und das hat dazu geführt
dass es ja auch in der politik und in
der gesellschaft bisher nicht ein ein
wirkliches zusammengehörigkeit die
folgen auch dem gedanken nicht dass die
deutschen die franzosen auch die
italiener auch friedensplan jetzt in
aller erster linie nach vorne schieben
dass wir eben an den frieden denken
müssen und ein ein verhandlungsergebnis
und ein ziel ausrufen müssen dass der
frieden lautet und es die anderen länder
gibt die auf viel mehr herz plädieren
sie sehen auch diese dissonanz nicht und
sagen sind es werden andere akzente
gesetzt das ist klar und sie erklären
sich auch aus der auch aus der
historischen wahrnehmung aus der
historischen erfahrung dass das gibt es
alles und ich habe ja eingangs auch
schon gesagt ich finde so viel reden von
verhandlungen und frieden momentan aber
den falschen zeitpunkt das zu tun und
diese stimmen gibt es auch deutschland
frankreich italien auch an anderen
anderen orten aber ich sehe sie nicht
als die als die dominante stimmung die
aus der eu und auch aus den den
hauptstädten der eu auch aus diesen drei
ländern nicht nicht kommt also ich
glaube da ist da ist etwas
übersteigertes dran an dieser dieser
diese differenz auf machen zu wollen und
damit schaden wir uns nur selbst das
größte gut ist wirklich so einig wie
möglich und da sind ja schon überall
grenzen wenn man die wirtschaftlichen
interessen denken aber brauchen die
abhängigkeiten denken aber das größte
gut ist so einig wie möglich aufzutreten
und das ist das nur ist wir denken uns
das ja nicht aus also hier wird die
deutsche und die französische regierung
richtig beschimpft und das ist auch nur
eine eine zusammenfassung von äußerungen
der letzten sechs wochen ich frage dann
auch nochmal danach sind die osteuropäer
tatsächlich so zornig auf die deutschen
dass sie jetzt auch nach diesem nach den
moralischen hinweisen die sie von uns in
der flüchtlingskrise bekommen haben und
in finanzkrisen bekommen haben dass sie
den deutschen jetzt mal richtig auch
gerne eine mitgeben wollen oder sehen
sie einen substanziellen unterschied
auch in den zielen also ist es eine
kampagne oder gibt es tatsächlich an
unterschiedlichen hats auch auf coaching
also ich glaube da hat sich viel wie
vorausgesagt viel aufgestaut und wir
reden über deutschland natürlich
deutschland ist auch deutschland noch
keine hippiekommune deutschland hat
einen großen und rüstungsindustrie
deutschland beliefert länder wie saudi
arabien ägypten an und nur an die
ukraine zum beispiel wollte man nicht
liefern um putin ist zu verärgern ende
letzten jahres während anfangs viel über
die türkei gerettet und noch mal eine
lanze für die türkei aufzubrechen auch
selbst
dass erdogan regime erdogan hat die
bayraktar die türkei hat die bayraktar
kampfdrohnen geliefert die in dem
anfangs gerade in den ersten wochen des
krieges große große verdienste geleistet
haben und die verteidigung der ukraine
bis hin dass heute ukrainische kinder
die in der stadt geboren wurden
hamburg cannes gegeben wurde in und
während deutschland noch vor ende
letzten jahres was man als 5000 helfer
geschickt hat und eigentlich glauben und
seite und seither zeigt ja seid ja sagt
ja gibt es glaube ich mag sein das
logistisch ist das logistische problem
gibt die ich nicht nachvollziehen kann
warum norwegen das jetzt glaube ich auch
keine ganz so groß waffenindustrie hat
schwere waffen liefern kann und
deutschland wird die sieben ende bis
ende juni geliefert haben aber das tape
neben dem technischen glaube ich gibt es
so eine prozesse gibt es eine situation
die sich dass sich auch nicht versteht
die sich immer wieder wiederholt das
waren ende letzten jahres noch überhaupt
bei waffenlieferungen das war damals bei
nordsee 2 und an jedem punkt haben wir
die situation
wir hatten vor zwei monaten hat nur noch
diese wirklich groteske situation über
offensive und defensive als auch als sei
das eine frage des materials nicht der
rollenverteilung also als müsste man in
deutschland müssen wir das nicht wissen
dass im zweiten weltkrieg natürlich der
sowjetischen t 34 panzer und der
britische kampfbomber das waren
defensive waffen und der der deutsche
wehrmacht herren bei einer offensive war
fußball-deutschland der aggressor bat
das ist keine frage des materials und
das lässt sich glaube ich seit allein im
letzten halben jahr immer wieder
durchdeklinieren und nicht verstehe ist
ehrlich gesagt am ende auch nicht warum
die bundesregierung unter bundeskanzler
immer wieder diese warum jetzt diese
diskussion aber ist dass wir dass wir
diese diskussion auch liefern die glaube
ich diesen eindruck da kommt nicht von
ungefähr und das er zuvor unter seeba
dass sie dass sie ihre regelungen
natürlich auch verteidigen aber ich
glaube ich finde das bit oder anders ich
finde das bedauerlich jetzt in diesem
moment in dieser frage dass sich ihre
partei den die bundeskanzlerin stellt
weil ich glaube diese diese entwicklung
hätten in den letzten monaten so nicht
gehabt es sind es sind in wieder diese
fehler den man macht die natürlich auch
einen eindruck erwecken dass wir hier
sehr solidarisch sind wir machen track
kospi konzerte und wir beleuchten das
brandenburger tor und wir sind alle
total solidarisch aber irgendwann reicht
die symbolische die ist wichtig aber
steht das historisch modernes
deutschland sein sterben und
einsatzwagen ansatz florida nachricht an
den letzten satz natürlich natürlich
vollkommen recht die die militärische
hilfe kann die zivile die humanitäre
auch die symbolische hilfe und
unterstützung nicht ersetzen das völlig
klar kann die sense ich glaube halt
umgekehrt wird dieser satz auch
haben jetzt so viel über die waffen
geredet weil die liste dieser man kann
ja auch über swift treten über das
bankensystem trage man kann auch über
man kann auch über drüber reden dass wir
bei den gaslieferungen bei allen
energiefragen als deutsche blockiert
haben und die wahrnehmung die bei den
trends bei dem ein spieler jetzt
deutlich geworden ist ist nun mal so es
ist europäische wahrnehmung wenn heute
wenn heute gefallen würde theoretisch
wenn die wenn die ukraine heute
verlieren würde dann würde europaweit
vielleicht sogar weltweite eindruck dass
in deutschland die schuld daran das ist
das gefühl dass das gefühl ist als ich
will nicht sagen dass alle
entscheidungen falsch machen ich will
nicht sagen dass das allein die
verantwortung ist sich gegen den blick
in die zukunft jetzt mal in zwei wochen
werden sich die staats und
regierungschefs in brüssel treffen da
geht es um die frage ob die ukraine
kandidatenstatus bekommt gestern war der
ukrainische parlament präsentieren sich
straßburg im europäischen parlament zu
gast und ich habe das gespräch mit ihm
gehabt und die ukraine nehmen das jetzt
also frage war
lohnt es zu kämpfen sagt sonst bitte
ehrlich sind wir willkommen dürften für
teil der eu werden und ich sage ihnen
mit allen staats und regierungschefs mit
denen ich spreche in der europäischen
union die sagen mir wir kriegen kein
signal aus dem kanzleramt annalena
baerbock oder position wieder einmal
ledergerber cfo position dazu die ich
durchaus schätze aber im kanzleramt
kriegen wir keine position übrigens auch
aus dem élysée haus nicht die zwei
großen länder die das ziel haben die die
aufgabe haben europa zu führen weil sie
noch mal die zwei großen länder sind wo
hingeschaut wird führen derzeit nennen
das ist unser problem das wir haben und
das ist das versagen auch dieser
regierung wo ich zwar anerkennen dass es
bei den grünen durchaus akzente gibt
aber die durchsetzungsfähigkeit ist
offensichtlich nicht da das im
kanzleramt ankommt und übrigens darüber
hinaus brauchen wir jetzt endlich eine
diskussion wir haben vorher die amerika
diskussion sehr intensiv geführt was
passiert denn in zwei jahren wenn ein
bisschen längerfristig blicken was
passiert in zwei jahren wenn donald
trump oder ein ein geist des bruder von
luke donald trump ins waisenhaus
zurückkommt die europäer sind derzeit
nackt in einer welt von stürmen es sind
nicht verteidigungs fähig sind nicht
verteidigungsfähigkeit wir sind
diplomatisch mit dem einstimmigkeit
orbán thema nicht in der lage uns
politisch zu positionieren wenn es
notwendig ist deshalb ist die zweite
aufgabe die berlin und paris jetzt hätte
und auch da kommt keine initiative die
aufnahme das war neu einen neuen vertrag
für europa jetzt gestalten wir brauchen
neue machtstruktur in dieser
europäischen union leistungsfähig sind
und sagt die stimme von morgen sie war
nämlich ein prinzip ist denn die in die
vielleicht lassen sie jetzt frau
zwischendurch
ist
da liegt ein vorwurf in der luft der der
lautet wenn die ukraine scheiterte frau
roth und auch das kann ja immer noch
passieren wenn die ukraine scheitert
oder aber einen nennenswerten teil
seines gebietes hergeben muss dann kann
es auch heißen dass die deutsche
regierung daran wenigstens mit schuld
ist dann sind viele mitverantwortlich
aber dann ist nicht deutschland schuld
also mit verlaub das finde ich wirklich
nicht akzeptabel ich will mal eine sagen
warum sind wir in einer situation
dass wir abhängig sind von putin wir
sind objektiv abhängig wir sind immer
noch abhängig bei allen bemühungen die
robert habeck jetzt ja
mit erfährt nach katar als grüner und
verhandelt und muster verhandeln aber
ich sogar tages haben damit ihr tun
deshalb tatsächlich damit zu tun dass
durch nord stream und eine unglaubliche
abhängigkeit entstanden ist das ist und
das war ein fehler das waren die
osteuropäer auch das verstehe ich weil
es gab es waren europäische länder die
massiv davor gewarnt haben und die alles
versucht haben dass das nicht passiert
dass es auch eine mitverantwortung wäre
daher über in ihrer
regierungsbeteiligung aber ich mache
jetzt hier nicht so einfach so so so so
parteien bashing also wir müssen so
schnell wie wirklich weg von diesen
abhängigkeiten und noch einmal zu sagen
dass handys lieber dennis
wir sind eine partei
die sich der gewaltfreiheit verpflichtet
hat wir haben rüstungsexportrichtlinien
als bundesrepublik deutschland da stehen
wichtige grundsätze drin und ich bin
ehrlich gesagt froh dass wir nicht in
der regierung sind die sofort sofort
sagt das ist überhaupt keine frage was
rüstungsgüter exporte angeht sondern
dass man damit sich ringt dass man sagt
wie habeck ich stimme jetzt
rüstungsexporten zu wissend wissend dass
das auch menschenleben kosten ja früher
gesagt der hat früher gesagt ich hab ihn
dafür kritisiert es kann immer sagen
claudia roth was du so naiv oder was du
so was nur so vertragstreu dass du
gesagt dass wir wollen keine
rüstungsexporte im kriegs und
krisengebiete liefern das war der anfang
tatsächlich die haltung auch von
annalena baerbock die gesagt hat wir
müssen auf alles alles alles versuchen
diesen krieg zu beenden
diesen krieg zu verhindern dass er sich
weiter eskaliert wir müssen auf
diplomatie setzen wir haben gemerkt mit
herrn putin kann man nicht auf
diplomatie setzen also haben wir
beschlossen
umfassende rüstungsgüter rüstungsgüter
zu ermöglichen und es muss man diesen
weg nicht noch sie sind weg dieses
dieses dieses ringen damit was ist das
richtige was ist nach etwa
drei stunden lang war es doch
geschrieben worden ist mit den fehlern
im rückblick wenn sie mit der ukraine
sprechen dann sagen ihnen dies ist toll
dass sich der deutsche bundespräsident
beschuldigt wird anerkannt ich glaube
hier deutsche sagen dann auch respekt er
hat auch das eingeräumt aber in der
ukraine treffen sehr viele leute die
sagen wenn in deutschland sicher
politiker entschuldigt dann geht man zum
nächsten thema über ihr bezahlen dass
derzeit das wieder gemacht deswegen ist
leute jetzt
eine ganz andere eine ganz andere wir
haben das diskutiert die frage wie geht
es in europa weiter und ich sage ihnen
natürlich haben die mittel osteuropäer
sich in den letzten jahren als europäer
zweiter klasse gefühlt natürlich haben
wir sie so behandelt und man ganz klar
sagen sehr oberlehrerhaft von westen
über geschaut und ihn vorschläge gemacht
wie denn eigentlich das richtig zu
funktionieren hat und für mich ist dann
dieser kiew moment den wir leben in
europa er hat zwei seiten einerseits
dass die osteuropäer wirklich
selbstbewusste auftreten und das tut
europa gut dass sie auftreten weil sie
was beibringen beitragen dass auch uns
im westen gut tut weil die politik ganz
anders verstehen ganz existenziell
verstehen mit den umbrüchen die sie
erlebt haben und auf der anderen seite
also vor der kirche momentum das
positive auch zu sagen mit finnland
schweden dänemark und letztes wochenende
abstimmung will der eu verteidigungs und
beiträgen der volksabstimmung wir
erleben ein zusammenrücken weil die
menschen schockiert seien von der
russischen brutalität und auch von dem
willen der ukraine beeindruckt sein
dieser kniff moment hilft uns auch
diesen kontinent zusammenzuhalten und
möchte noch eine letzte frage ben hodges
stellen weil ich noch mal denke dass es
ganz klug ist nach den zielen zu fragen
die osteuropäer sagen und die balten
ziemlich eindeutig putin ist ein
faschist und deshalb kommt herr du da
übrigens auch auf diesen vergleich mit
den telefonaten und mit hitler
wie ist das mit den zielen die wir
definieren auch aus us amerikanischer
sicht hieß ist am anfang wir müssen
putin bekämpfen dieser mann darf nicht
gewinnen darf diesen krieg nicht
gewinnen jetzt wird gesagt der ukraine
muss geholfen werden möglichst eine gute
position an den verhandlungstisch zu
haben gibt es auch in washington
eine zahl von zweiflern
imagination
kann mir schon vorstellen dass es auch
in washington menschen gibt die
vielleicht zögerlich sind aber die sind
in der minderheit und was ich im
augenblick höre sehe und auch lese auch
zuhören pflege von menschen cohen
führungspositionen dass wir dem ziel uns
verschrieben haben denen auch der
außenminister aus werden dann
beziehungsweise verteidigt mit dem
ausland gesagt habe nämlich dass wir der
ukraine helfen wollen zu gewinnen wenn
es darum geht
das souveräne territorium der ukraine
vollständig zurück zu finden
einschließlich der krim und des donners
aber ich glaube die erwartung ist
eigentlich das gelände des jahres hat
sich spätestens sich dann auch die dinge
wenden während wenn das gesamte material
geliefert worden wird das worden ist
dass dann die dinge sich ändern wäre ja
denn im augenblick sehen wir schon dass
die russischen streitkräfte erschöpft
sind und dass sie das nicht
aufrechterhalten werden können gegen
ende des jahres wird es also sein dass
ikonische streitkräfte dicken die
russischen streitkräfte
bis auf die linien im februar zurück
schieben können in der krim und im don
boscos das natürlich sehr viel länger
gebrannt und das wird wahrscheinlich
auch eher das ergebnis einer
verhandelten in einigung sein das mag
vielleicht einige jahre dauern
hoffentlich nicht die 45 jahre die es
für deutschland gebraucht hat um wieder
für einig zu werden aber das ist die
erklärte politik der vereinigten staaten
und ich hoffe auch dass deutschland die
volle wiedervereinigung der ukraine
anstreben sollten dass wir alles tun
werden dass das auch wirklichkeit wird
und damit sind wir noch mal beim materie
sind in washington jetzt bekommt die
ukraine vielleicht immer die eu
mitgliedschaft angeboten oder die
kandidatur dafür ist dass mehr eine art
trostpflaster eben weil die nato
mitgliedschaft nicht mehr in frage
kommen
na ja da sagt man hier in washington da
gibt es ja auch den artikel 42 7 in den
eu-verträgen der auch eine
beistandspflicht auslöst wenn er land
angegriffen wird allerdings wird es
nicht ganz gezielt nur auf militärisch
dann fokussiert sondern das kann auch
andere form von beistand sein aber es
gibt diese beistandspflicht ich will zu
der diskussion mal wird wenn ich sagen
darf mal die amerikanische sicht hier
aus dem weißen haus ist die dass das was
da passiert ein lackmustest ein weckruf
ist für ganz europa deswegen ist der
amerikanische präsident am 26 märz im
königlichen schloss in warschau so
aufgetreten dass er gesagt hat hey hier
ist der beweis für das was er schon eine
ganze weile behauptet die welt befindet
sich in der großen auseinandersetzung
zwischen autoritarismus und demokratie
und die länder osteuropas nicht alle
aber viele
das abgenommen dass da jetzt einer ist
der sagt ja das ist die
auseinandersetzung die usa sind an eurer
seite und wir erwarten dass alle bündnis
partner das auch sind und
interessanterweise war ja schon vor dem
ukraine krieg ist so dass vor allen
dingen in paris und in berlin und in
einigen anderen west- europäischen
hauptstädten den amerikanern nicht
geglaubt wurde als sie gesagt hatten
dass der aufmarsch stattfindet dass
putin diesen krieg beginnen wird
de informationen weitergegeben worden
bis zum abwinken und es wurde nicht
geglaubt dann ist es passiert und dann
sagt der präsident so und jetzt kommt im
raum der test wir müssen alles tun dass
der autoritarismus nicht gewinnt und
wenn man dann das wort zeitenwende in
den mund nimmt so wird das hier in
washington gesehen dann müssen ja auch
dementsprechend die taten folgen die
wahrheit ist aber so wird das hier
wahrgenommen vor kurzem war hier das
leaders meeting der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz in washington da
wurde sehr klar dass die europäer aber
vor allen dingen die deutschen der
meinung sind das ist erst mal nur der
imperialismus von putin den müssen wir
stoppen und dann gucken wir mal wie sich
das wieder zurecht schütteln aber wir
haben es hier nicht mit der ganz großen
auseinandersetzung zwischen
autoritarismus und demokratie zu tun und
deswegen kann so was passieren wie heute
passiert ist heute hat der russische
präsident sich quasi in einer reihe mit
peter den grossen den zaren gestellt und
gesagt man hat ja jetzt eigentlich nur
das territorium wieder geholt was
eigentlich russland gehört und am
gleichen tag laufen teile der russischen
flotte aus in der ostsee und stellen
eine bedrohung dafür finnland und
schweden bis zu dem punkt dass heute am
abend der finnische präsident und das
schwedische königspaar auf aland dem
neutralen gebiet einer inselgruppe die
da liegt die finnland verwaltet aber die
als neutral gilt wo russland auch
interessen hat die zu einem jahrestag zu
einem jubiläum da gewesen sind heute die
polter diese feierlichkeiten verlassen
haben warum weil sie sich bedroht
gefühlt haben mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit das kann ich nicht
beweisen aber das heißt doch dass ein
putin weiter diese drohungen ausführen
kann und die große frage ist die sich
dann auch die osteuropäer stellen wo
sind dann die regierungen in berlin
paris und anderswo die mal öffentlich
sagen das geht so nicht und die das
verteidigen und alles tun damit finnland
und schweden möglichst schnell in die
nato kommt und wir sind froh um in
diesen gedanken aufzunehmen bei der
frage was tun
die länder deutschland und frankreich
jetzt klugerweise um diesen eindruck zu
zerstören dass sie
eben nicht mit der gleichen emphase mit
der mit der gleichen import tanz genau
dieses ziel verfolgen ein wichtiger
moment jetzt im juni wird sein die
entscheidung ob die ukraine den
kandidatenstatus bekommen kann für die
eu-mitgliedschaft die dann noch sicher
ein langer weg wäre ich glaube dass da
auch georgien und mal damit dabei ist
untersagt ist wie das muss klar vorhaben
dahin umgegangen ist oder muss
glaubwürdig sein und das wird natürlich
auch an den eu erweiterungsprozess
verändern dass wir die eu verändern aber
da gibt es in der jetzigen situation
eigentlich kein kein zurück und kein
zaudern und da würde man sich jetzt
wünschen dass sowohl aus paris als auch
aus berlin ganz klare zeichen kommen
dass das unterstützt wird und
kandidatenstatus ist ja in der eu logik
nur der erste schritt von ganz vielen
das heißt das könnte länger dauern muss
ja auch nicht so lange dauern wie es bei
einigen gedauert hat aber das wäre jetzt
ein wichtiges politisches signal
und das ist auf keinen fall ein
trostpflaster oder nur etwas
symbolisches ist und auch wenn man
diesen status hat und wenn dann noch mal
abgestimmt wird das auch verhandlungen
beginnen könnten dann werden auch
weitere mittel frei dann kann man über
auch weitere reformen in der ukraine da
kann man über wiederaufbau der ukraine
ganz anders nachdenken als man das ohne
diesen ersten schritt könnte das heißt
dafür davon hängt viel ab und hinzu
kommt natürlich die die große bedeutung
die das für für für die für die ukraine
ukrainerinnen zum jetzigen zeitpunkt hat
also das signal was davon ausgeht aber
dann auch aus der aus der praktischen
überlegung her wenn es zum teil zb heißt
dass wir hohe kosten nieder auf die eu
zukommen die kommen ohnehin über den
wiederaufbau auf die eu zu das heißt
besser macht man es doch dann in diesem
rahmen und gibt auch der eu da eine
aktive rolle auch diesen prozess der ja
auch lange dauern wird und der wirklich
viel kosten wird
mit zu gestalten und mit den ukrainern
zusammen zu gestalten das argument von
frau von